parliamentarians in Malawi don't have a
lot of time to arrange another
presidential election first they have to
set a date then enact legislation
ordered by the Constitutional Court but
all that could be delayed by president
Peter Metallica's planned to appeal to
the Supreme Court ruling to overturn his
reelection last May
so as France we are concerned we go by
the directions that we have unless if
the Supreme Court comes up with
something different or if indeed there's
a stay or down the matter they would
have to change direction depending on
the new direction on Monday five judges
nullify the result of Mays election
saying it was marred by widespread
irregularities Metallica says he's
appealing the judgement because it's
full of errors that needed to be
corrected the president is ready his
party's ready for an erection actually
the president would love a fresh
election to prove the point that he had
the legitimate mandate from the people
but we have to respect them all the
democratic processes
Metallica won the election with a thirty
eight point five percent share of the
vote opposition leader Lazarus Shakira
came second with thirty five point four
percent and solace Geneva had twenty
points to four percent in the final
tally the Constitutional Court advised
Parliament to consider removing the
current Electoral Commission to try and
make sure the next election is more
credible in an attempt to avoid disputes
the winner will need to get more than
50% of the vote the election result
dispute has provoked matter
demonstrations in several parts of the
country some of the protests had been
violent at least one police officer and
the civilian were killed
protesters say there'll be more mass
action until the election is rerun so
the pediment is starting to meet on
Monday immediately they start to meet
they'll be seeing the fire from the
citizens we would want them to do the
right things if they think they're going
to play games with us we are going to
tell them get out of our Parliament we
are going there as a people and make
decisions for the betterment of our
country
opposition supporters celebrated when
they heard enumeration is to be held but
the president's plan to appeal the
judgment has put a damper on their mood
and wrist inflaming tensions further
heart Matassa al Jazeera no longer